what's happening there reject nation we
are going to watch ourselves some arcane
episode 5 today guys if you can hit that
like button that'd be very much
appreciated subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction for our queen is look
full-length watch songs we're seeing
about the tag quarter on our patreon we
cover a bunch of shows over there as
well i thank you to the boys at prepper
for writing on these highlights i just
want to watch this let's get to it
[Music]
wow
[Music]
crack shot for me knowing how to handle
this weapon means being able to protect
people
to be of service to the city
that's trophy enough
nah
what are you shooting for to be better
than her parents
a way out or something deeper
uh-oh where did you get this
my question first
you work for silke uh they all do how
can anyone not know that where did you
find this
i've got orders from councillor talis
concerning inmate 516.
not cooperative huh
you uh you want us to have a chat with
her
no
oh
no you're so surprised
what are you guys doing
[Music]
i like caitlyn more already yep
[Laughter]
that's why you just say something in a
review
very nice
[ __ ] yeah you've got a little flashback
even got a little bit of endearing
flashback
it just sounds so redundant to say how
great the camera works
[Laughter]
who was this daddy
i'm a counselor now victor it's my
responsibility to make sure the heck
skates are safe and protected what about
our pledge to improve lives
for those in need that can wait 10 years
at least
chief suspect is an undercity gang
they call themselves
he's trying to fight to get to the point
where he wants to live to see the
successful man
turns it on
so
here goes
[Music]
oh [ __ ] she can't bring her friends back
to life
oh
memories
oh boy
[Music]
damn violet
is she gonna keep up with you kate is
halfway back across town
i'm still not following they think
they adapt
you think hextech can learn artificial
intelligence oh careful buddy
don't creed hexnet there are those who
covet your power over the wealth the
hexagates afford and would take any
opportunity to seize it from you
you've just made yourself everyone's
common enemy jace
maybe you shouldn't have voted for him
to become a councilman yeah assess that
risk it's only a second day
how dare you kill the cat moment
[Music]
wow
oh no damn
just like trauma walking around in human
form yeah you're hurting down deep the
council assumes you'll fail time to
prove them all wrong
once again
then we'll do a jump cut to
have jobs to show 20 more years later
the hex gates are only the beginning in
fact we're currently looking for new
partners in our hextech research and as
a supporter of house telus you'd be the
first in line to any of our advancements
i can't tell if what chase is doing as a
writer i think you're right on track
because i think it's teetering on wrong
whether he likes it or not he's a
politician now
if you really want people to talk to you
you have to let them think you have what
they want
and what do i have
you're hot cupcake
i'm pam
what's your name matilda but
you can call her whatever you want
oh
yeah matilda
my parents named me more parents no one
where are they they're in a brothel i'd
like to go to one of these brothels one
day let's go red light district costume
parties
definitely yeah
one final act to make you the martyr
you've always seen yourself ass
whoa
what
that's a good job yeah
then what are you waiting for
damn you guys coward you're the only one
i can trust with is jinx
i keep
seeing them
that day fair hansa
child such a weasel
seriously damn silk
that's exactly when to talk down
have you heard anything about powder
i think silko has her
uh
everyone knows about
her
who's gonna be the first to tell
you did well today
i had a good teacher i'll trust you lady
imagine the wonders they could create if
we left magic in their hands
the world will never be the same
the medadas usually only take from the
world
we're not often in the position to give
anything back
no but what about caitlyn who might be
gay
careful my guy
i don't trust her at all man as much as
i like her vibe
[Music]
wow they're really making it out yeah
that hadn't been a while i don't think
i've ever seen an animated kiss that
fleshed out
oh
it's gonna do something with his blood
it's gonna like fuse with his blood or
something
blood magic
[Music]
ha ha
wow
wow i was like psychedelic yeah
this is what that sex scene and internal
should have been
i almost drowned in these waters you
told me a million times get over it geez
you need to let powder die
so the fear of pain will no longer
control you
become the jinx
[Music]
i love their use of povs mm-hmm
this magic dragon is going to make a
cameo maybe
is that dead
looks kind of weird
not exactly like them but kinda
oh no
how much time do i have
the end of the episode
oh no what the hell oh god she got like
a robo arm
oh
no oh yeah that's how she she had the
lines on earlier yeah
well don't go for the robot arm
such great fighting yeah
[Music]
such a badass brawler i love it yeah
i damage her damage her
wow
and that's what having enhanced serum
and a bucky barn's arm
you mean jinx she works for him
she's a secret weapon you
[Music]
she's like his daughter
[Music]
come on bye
where are you caitlin
i'll give her your regards
[Applause]
[Music]
that's so cool they brought it back
perfect
i love it and it emerges just like the
targets did yeah that's great
that's awesome
you're an all right shot
i'm an excellent shot [ __ ]
the sister
she's back
i've just got her over the trauma yeah
the dead
so she's just been hiding this whole
time
i guess maybe where's she been hiding
in prison
she's just been in prison all this time
i don't know i mean they said that that
one thing when she goes when caitlyn
goes in there about like you know they
they don't have almost any information
on her whatever she's just there
i don't know
silco i really thought she was dead oh
my gosh
he always wants to play that guy yeah
he's a real playboy
free stranger
copper
copper
copper it's time to grow up and get a
job
you can't play every day in his mouth
now he dropped the toy he wants me to go
up there
that cat
okie dokie well caitlyn shot up a lot of
my book yeah she's awesome hell yeah
she's awesome she's like really awesome
i love the book end with her too yeah
yeah it was a nice prologue it was nice
to get even though you know we were
talking about the time jump last episode
was nice to jump back for a minute she
just never wanted to be treated special
she never wanted to be treated with
privilege yeah she wants to earn her way
in the world
and uh yeah she hates being like
having oh my gosh copper
we've got a lot of opinions on the
shrimp
yeah
she's awesome i i thought she's great i
like the chemistry between her and
violet a lot yeah
and violet is oh man i can't decide i
really like what they're doing with jinx
a lot especially that scene where she
was like going back to their former
hideout
and the way they do and deal with that
like the opaque nature and the flashes
of everything that's happening there
those quick little glimpses
and the way they seamlessly intertwine
uh the flashbacks almost as in like
these mirroring ways yeah was so
beautifully done and
i love how tortured she is and also this
like
gaslighting manipulative way that silko
has done yeah
of it's like you know someone talks to
me that way i i'd be
i'd be like i'd probably fall for it too
you know yeah this is like yeah you're
not wrong you know you got to free
yourself from the past and stuff
let that person die yeah kill them if
you have to kill them if you have to
merge anew
into your power
i like that they're doing i mean i like
what they're doing with jinx yeah
because it's it's one of those situ
instances where i can
feel powder somewhere in there deep deep
deep down inside
but at the moment you know like i i feel
like you could stand back and go well
you know part of the journey's got to be
that maybe her and violet will come back
together but i really honestly don't
know like it seems i mean when they have
their their confrontation i'm sure
that's going to be a big moment but um
but yeah i i like the nuance of that
because you can still feel jinx and
powder kind of struggling against each
other
in small ways whereas jinx is like
really kind of
his is inching towards being her full
form
you know and obviously that that moment
with silco is taking us even closer to
there but yeah like all her little
psychosis moments and and also like just
the glitches and the weird stuff they
work into that they're really
sensory and unnerving
yeah that's a good way to put it
i think with her i would i would
i mean just as in terms of a character
i would probably say that
i mean jinx is just a facade and
jinx is not who she really is
um at least that's why i'm taking it
like she's clearly still the little girl
on the inside you know like that's all
she this whole thing that she's built is
all stemmed from escaping
what she's done and who she really is
underneath all that yeah that's where it
all comes from you know is that her
child she's trying to be jinxed like
everything around her that jinx has
created it is a constant reminder of who
she really is internally that no matter
what kind of
bravado
it puts on it's just nothing more than a
mask
and so that's where the the hope comes
in like she does
devilish deeds and whatnot and she's
she's manic but that's all a sign of
someone who just straight up ptsd
and i like the way they capture her and
that that framing and then she's with
someone who's very manipulative
and
the way how he operates is so
just so goddamn sadistic man
and he's and they're great at playing
his whole line of being like i'm going
to be very warm and i'm going to
encourage you but you just know how
sinister he is at the core
i like that they don't like i like the
characterization of him generally though
because you can see easily how people
might be manipulated by this guy yeah in
the first three episodes you're just
like this dude's straight up people hey
he's got the evil look he's got the evil
demeanor the way he talks yeah but now
there's more of a confidence to into
morbid to a swagger
allowing people to see that sometimes he
comes across sincere yeah and i can see
how this guy has a strong following in
the wake of vander you know being gone
even if it is toxic and poisonous yeah
well
another thing that i really loved about
this show that really stood out to me in
terms of the visual direction
is beyond all the many things we've
always talked about with the action is
they they really know how to make
objectivity um
feel so massive in scale
depending on where they prop the camera
yeah they like lock on to something
that's close to their pov to their eye
line they can make objects just seem
massive yeah and i love that effect like
it works in an emotional way and
sometimes it just looks so badass
you have a really expressive use of
perspective and and angles and and i
feel like that part kind of reminds me
of anime in a certain way
like in a way that doesn't
break and medley its form as much as
anime like this is really really unified
in terms of how the animation and the
visuals are realized but they still have
that extreme sense of scale and
perspective
and what violet what's fascinating about
her is that she's also
equally traumatized in her own way
except she's not
filled with this sense of guilt
well i might push back against that i
think that actually she probably does
have guilt for feeling like she
abandoned her sister yeah it's like in
that moment of what we saw in episode
three
yeah it makes sense of why she acted the
way she did it's like who the [ __ ]
wouldn't
however after some time has passed you
know it's like they both kind of miss
and eat each other a little bit oh yeah
they're both hurting they grew up
together yeah yeah and they both got to
miss each other
deep deep deep down and vander i mean
like you know there's also that
connecting them too is you know van der
waals their father figure
well it's i like what they've how
they've evolved their characters as
violet was more
she's more fun yeah she's got more of
this sarcastic edge to her yeah
but you can still feel that anger and
pain within her
uh where like in the first three
episodes she was more just more angsty
and obviously we've talked a lot about
how powder has evolved into who she is
now
the credit the credits
credit her as jinx though you know yeah
so
that's what that's the part where i
become a little bit hesitant because i'm
like nah i think she's still just powder
underneath it all right you know
i mean you know i think that's also
probably just to denote like oh she's
older now but yeah i feel like that's
part of her characters that grappling
between powder and jinx and i love that
when she's playing when she's you know
doing the the boxing game or whatever
the leaderboard still says pow
well i think a big part of like
that's what i mean is she's trying to
she misses that part of her past yeah
and also in some ways you can kind of
read into it
as
who powder became was her trying to live
up to who violet is oh absolutely and so
putting up the boxing stuff
and and doing all that watching how she
evolved it's like she just went down a
different path yeah but physically and
what she's capable of is equal to
violence it's like you got to get a
fight between the two of them yeah
it's going to be heavy that's going to
be harsh it's going to be a harsh thing
to unpack there that fight with sevika
or savika whatever her name is with the
the arm you know like that was intense
and a lot for vi to handle
and she handled i mean you know she
needed help ultimately at the end she
held her own but like when she and jinx
square off i can only imagine it's gonna
be that much
heavier of a showdown
because jinx has i mean she's had all
this time to if there's one thing she's
definitely improved at it's making all
our inventions work
what was the serum that silko invented
that power-up serum yeah
uh
i don't remember what the true nature of
it is because how has he gone to like
distribute all that you know
yeah i mean you know we saw it as like a
prototype i feel like or you know yeah
early stages in that first episode with
deckard or second episode where he you
know gives it he's i gotta kind of if
i'm remembering correctly i got one of
those like well we gotta try it on a
person now yeah yeah and so it seems
like since then he's probably had a lot
of time to perfect and uh you know
refine that tech and maybe powders had
something jinx has had something to do
with that
but uh i mean yeah it's certainly
advanced and it's certainly integrated
into you know tech because it seems like
the way they're using
because
i thought there'd be a little bit more
use of that but i guess it's just used
as a form of muscle
i guess
i mean i don't know it seems kind of a
rat it seems like it would be hard to
use it for anything other than that
because of how kind of it seems like
like civic is able to control it a
little better because i remember
controls the doses yeah and i mean like
in that fight in the warehouse with
vander and everything it seemed like it
made them a bit more erratic that's true
that's true so you are like kind of
literally hulking out whereas now it
feels more of just like a heavy power up
or something yeah yeah yeah
then we got that cop uh-huh yeah i have
a hard time feeling bad for i don't feel
bad for him at all
i'm like you're a dick i don't like you
i don't like him at all
i was almost starting to feel something
for him because yeah like in the first
act he's just so insufferable he's just
like such a because and especially
seeing him from that pov you know and
when when you know the the i feel like
under vanders rule of zon piltover
probably feels that much more powerful
whereas silko's is a little more dubious
and so i started to have pangs of like
ah
it's funny right when they did the fake
out with him blowing himself up i was i
almost blurted out oh i was just
beginning to maybe almost warm up to you
but i don't know i mean i'm also curious
to see what becomes of that character
because i could totally see them
sympathizing him more down the line but
yeah
he's uh
he's uh you know i don't see like
everything he's done like come on man
you helped get this guy to to the power
position that he's in yeah yeah yeah
like top of the corruption chain you
can't yeah it's like you gotta be
smarter than to count on your authority
here you know because yeah when vander
was in charge maybe there was a
different kind of arrangement but here
it's like you're not in charge man
and of course then we got jace
yes
which
it's just hard to find that as
compelling and interesting
i feel like i've been thinking about why
that might be and i feel like more so
than any other character we don't get as
much from his like
they they're good at putting you through
the camera and various other things
literally into various characters
perspectives whereas i don't feel like
we do that as much with jace we sort of
explore the circumstances surrounding
him what people want him to do
and you know he makes some interesting
and sort of nuanced choices within that
but i don't feel as much as though we
have been as personal with him as we
were when they were first cracking you
know when he and his partner were first
cracking the magic and all that well
also with this storyline i think
something that gets lost in the
time jump is that there's all they keep
telling us maybe there's something i
missed so feel free to let me know in
the comments yeah i'm just kind of
pondering right now
they
talk a lot about the hex tech
and how much that has influenced and
changed their entire city and everything
and
yeah we know
really get to see
how or why we just kind of they kind of
just keep telling us stuff
but we don't get to see really what
how the evolution has been affected by
it it doesn't feel like a huge part of
the society beyond the gate yeah and i
know they haven't like perfected it yet
and i mean there's more to do with it to
really have it be more like primal and
tangible and all that jazz but at the
same time that i don't
it's like they kind of just you just
hear them talk about it but you don't
you don't see the way like the people
have responded to this
or really what it's done you know for
the people it's like they just kind of
know about it
but we haven't seen that effect
and
uh
we spent so much time with the political
aspects of
the council and such
whereas like when you're in the under
city you know you got your people who
are just people who are part of the
undercity people like a violet you know
or you follow
oh my god all you guys right now are
choosing the worst time
to ask for my attention and i'm trying
to talk to the people at the same time i
got all you guys in the back of my head
i'm worried about y'all fighting
so
yes we have um
uh something about the people in the
lower cities you got the people in lower
city and then you got the people who in
the under city who you also see are at
the top of the food chain in the
undercity
whereas i i really feel like with um uh
pivitch what was called
pivotal
uh oh oh oh uh oh goodness prior
priority city yeah
i could i could pick pic picking pit
pivotal pi
pinocchio pippa lock pimple
that city
i i feel like we only hang out with the
higher ups yes like the top of the chain
so we don't get a real sense of the
of what this world is like for people
yeah and it was like teetering almost on
that when you were seeing like the
festivities and things like that for
progress day back in the last episode
but i'm just supposed to assume everyone
just has
like just super splendid i guess yeah it
would be nice to maybe have some more
street level in piltover yeah there we
go
yeah because i yeah that was something
that that had crossed my mind as well is
like when you go to zahn even if you
don't spend a ton of time there you meet
just the folks who inhabit the place and
you see what the life is in different
corners of their whereas piltover feels
like
everything is upscale and maybe that's
that's all maybe that's the way it is
but i spent so much time with people
talking about like
you know it's gonna affect thousands of
jobs in the city and the imports i don't
ever see any of that though you guys
keep talking about it so it makes me a
heart it makes it harder for me to
really care as much about what's going
on there and it makes the council feel
more isolated yeah and the energy of it
i mean bottom line is they just don't
put as much time into making the they
don't have any scenes that call for it
that's what i like about their
expressive use of the animation is that
they're they they really go all out and
go eccentric and become like wildly
eclectic and expressive when
the moment calls for it and that's
usually only with the underground people
under city people yeah but in the
upper part it's all just
you know politics and stuff so you don't
really get much of of the of like the
the the awesome animation things to do
because the scenes don't warrant it so
there's no reason to do it
at the same time though the story that
they're telling themselves i just i know
that by the end i i have so much faith
in this show though
that by the time we come to the ending
moments or when that you really see that
on the brink of like a
essentially it would be a civil war
because they're they're all the same
people just divide it right so
essentially become a civil war between
them
to some extent whatever's brewing right
now and that that will make all that
worth it like i totally get it you know
especially with jace wanting to actually
end the corruption and stuff like that
that
that will become rewarding and be a big
payoff it's just right now whenever we
cut to it
not as
uh
a more like okay i'm getting this i'm
it's interesting yeah but i'm not as
like emotionally i'm just not that i'm
not as engaged to it
uh even though i'm a little bit
concerned for jason how he's being
manipulated and becoming this pawn
yes yeah i'm i'm concerned for the
bigger scope of that and interested in
the bigger scope of that and i feel like
the most expressive element of the pilt
over stuff was with victor where he's
having these strange visions anything to
do with the hex magic yeah
yeah i thought that stuff like that's
that was the most interesting stuff
there this episode i mean like
the political entry
it does get me to an extent but yeah
feeling more of the effect and more of
the sort of i feel the intertwining
politics so again these few leaders that
we keep seeing
but not so much yeah the the overarching
okay like you feel the effects on zaun
just because they do so much to
highlight the disparity and the fact
that you know
because they are neglected essentially
you know like that's the effect that
piltover has on them but yeah it would
be i think it would bolster the
political stuff to feel beyonds on what
the repercussions of that could be and i
mean that could also
divert focus like i understand why maybe
they're not trying to dive as hard into
there but i feel like it could bolster
some of the piltover stuff because it
also makes it a lot easier
to side with like with everybody in zahn
you know get really any personal thing
with the people of piltover to
latch or not latch on time and like in
the underground there's so much life in
different places they [ __ ] went to a
brothel in this episode yeah yeah like
all i ever feel like i see is the
council and labs
yeah it's all in that one big you know
central building yeah and i i don't get
a sense of anything else
and so i'd like to
if they if they did a little bit more
like i thought with the festivities you
might see more of that but obviously not
so real the real emotion real gripping
storytelling is all coming from the uh
the main people from the undercity
although i will give it i did i hope we
get more of like what's in the prologue
because with kate see like that was an
instance where i was like oh cool we're
seeing outside the city we're in the
countryside we're in like in a wealthy
countryside and we're at a function and
we're getting at least a little bit of a
personal thing
and so i feel like hate is the most
interesting piltover player right now
true that's very true
but yeah guys those are our thoughts for
today
uh we got episode six to get through now
[ __ ] great it's a great show it's
great good amazing amazing show act
three coming up then act three and you
know shit's really gonna hit the fan
yeah this is cool they got this like big
thing they're building to like the the
big thing but then you got a real
personal
personal story happening between violet
and powder yeah and that's probably the
that's like the best part of it
that's the yeah that's the heart yeah
because it's only the big thing and you
won't give a [ __ ] anything you know fair
enough all right guys are your thoughts
down below
we'll talk soon